thank you it's a great pleasure and a
great honor to be to be invited to give
a talk here actually I am impressed that
you are inviting Outsiders like like me
like a physicist in this audience and I
think probably from most people in
computer science it's clear that physics
has something to do with computer
science because it's it builds up all
these machines that can then be used but
also here I want to convince you that
physics maybe can provide an interesting
framework for for reasoning about
fundamental problems in the theory of
computation and I need to say a few
words about my my title it has two part
one is affirmative it says that more is
different and the other one is a
question mark and I my aim is to try to
convince you that the answer to the
question is yes more is different is
actually a sentence which is which is a
title of a paper by Phil Anderson a
famous Nobel Prize winner and one of the
most influential researchers in
condensed matter physics he wrote a
paper in science in 1972 that was the
title of the paper and it was a paper
about reductionism reductionism actually
it was it was part of a dispute between
condensed matter physicists and and
particle physicists and nuclear
physicists about what is the most
important part of physics and science
and I will not try to completely
summarize the the paper field but
basically he was of course arguing in
favor of reductionism but it was also
arguing in the fact that reductionism
does not mean does not imply a hierarchy
of science it does and the reason for
that is that it does not imply the
possibility to reconstruct that if you
have
a theory which explains you the
collective behavior of a lot of elements
of course it has to be disentangle and
you have to look at each element it's
special ingredient and the global
theories to be consistent with with the
behavior of each element but it's not
the the mere knowledge of the behavior
of each element does not imply that you
are able to to reconstruct the whole
thing and and so he puts here a kind of
hierarchy of science but not a hierarchy
in the sense of of one which is more
fundamental than the other because
basically the idea is that at each level
at each scale it's a hierarchy of scale
so you see you start with elementary
particle physics go to solid state
physics on many body physics many buddy
you go to chemistry chemistry you go to
molecular biology and so on there is no
computer science here for some for some
reason that you understand why but the
idea is that each item of the left
column has to be compatible with the
scale which is below it but it also
generates its own concepts methods and
and and results and let me let me show
you a couple of examples of what he had
in mind basically at the turn of the the
beginning of the of the 20th century you
could think that everything was known in
in physics you had Newton row or a few
years later you get Schrodinger equation
but still you have this fascinating
problem which is that you take such a
simple problem as water and h2o and you
take these molecules and you understand
pretty well how they interact and why
the hell comes that all of a sudden at a
certain temperature here it can be in
two possible phases two possible states
which are so different from one from the
other which is a liquid or solid so
the this this has been known the
mechanism has been well understood
scenes on Sagar
in 1944 so and Sagar was addressing the
issue in terms of magnets not in terms
so much of molecules of water so you
look at at at the magnet you look at the
microscopic behavior it has a lot of
spins of man in elementary magnetic
moment they interact and then you you
look at the interaction between these
these these spins it turns out that the
energy is is lower when the spins are
power than when they are anti power and
when you put that into Boltzmann's law
you have your favor it means that this
configuration is more probable than the
other one the thing that on cigar didn't
which was not at all obvious was to
realize that because of these at some
very specific temperature all of a
sudden this measure the interaction
between the spins don't change with
temperature but you you just change this
parameter at a certain critical
temperature there is a phase transition
the phase transition goes into a
collective state and the collective
state has the following properties first
of all most of the spins tend to align
so that you generate a spontaneous
magnetization in one direction but at a
given moment if you take a snapshot not
all the spins are aligned there is a
fraction of them which are in the wrong
direction then you take another another
snapshot and then other spins are in the
wrong direction but you always have the
same fraction which point back so it
means that this phase the phase which I
call spins up is a collective state and
it is very robust
you could you could now you can
introduce impurities in that sample you
can you can have some spins which are
missing you can have with some
interaction which are wrong and so on if
the if it is a small amount of disorder
you will have a stability of this magnet
and you can still orient yourself with
this magnet so this is a collective
state there is a phase transition at a
very well-defined temperature thousand
forty-three Kelvin for iron and that
happens only in the large and
thermodynamic limit so that's always
that's the thing which is very important
you need to have a large sample
so this is where more is important and
where more is different this is a
phenomenon of large size system actually
large size does not here in this case is
10 to the 23 but it does not mean that
it has to be so you use exactly the same
thing in in in your magnetic disks for
instance with domains which have size of
tens of nanometers so it's large n does
not a large n can be a million and then
there is spontaneous breaking of the
symmetry so you have actually two of
these states one of the states has
majority of spins pointing up the other
one has majority of spin pointing down
so for instance you you go here you go
to three-quarters over this is a
critical temperature and you have one
state where you have 80% of the spin
which point up the other one which has
80 percent of the spin which point down
not always the same spins and they
flipped it in time so this is this is
interesting it's a very robust state of
matter with nothing to do with well you
can use it for computation if you build
some very small magnetic domain so you
can store information in that but that's
not a big deal the thing that really was
a breakthrough in this in this sense for
in my opinion is the appearance of
discovery in the middle of the 70s of
systems which have our spin systems
which have many many states and these
are these are called spin classes like
impurities of manganese in copper and it
turns out that in this case the energy
between two spins can be either
ferromagnetic that is it is it favors
the spins pointing parallel or anti
ferromagnetic it means that the band
that depends on on the distance between
the two spins so you have this energy
function which characterized to spin the
Sigma I point up or down in my is plus
one or minus one and you have this
energy you put that in the Boltzmann
weight and you will ask the same
question is there a phase transition
well what is new with respect to what we
had before
the first thing is that it's a
disordered system so it's spin sees a
different local field it's not
homogeneous
at low temperature you have frustration
it means that you can have for instance
Triplets of spins which have all anti
ferromagnetic interaction you cannot
satisfy all the all the constraints so
it means that spins tend to freeze in
random direction it's also very
difficult to find the minimum of the
energy and actually it's a very
well-known np-hard problem so this
problem of spin glasses and this very
simple problem here you see you have a
basically you have Sigma I text value
plus or minus 1 you have capital j IJ
which are taken from a random Gaussian
distribution you ask the property what
is the property of this measure does it
have a phase transition at a finite
temperature very simple I can describe
the problem to you know in a few words
it's totally useless it has generated
tens of thousands of papers no grant
actually all the people who have been
working and that have been working I've
gotten the grant from other sources but
we're working on that as a as a passion
and and it has generated a lot of a lot
of ideas and they like it just to give
you one example of the strange
experimental behavior because these are
experimental systems they exist this is
a measure of the magnetic relaxation so
you put a spring glass you put it in a
magnetic field you measure the
magnetization magnetic field tends to
align the spins magnetization decays as
function of time here is after 400
minutes so you have to be very patient
because you see the system is relaxing
on the extremely long time scale it's a
very slow system that's why it's called
a glass classical glasses in that
relaxed is extremely slowly and then
this was relaxing at 12 Kelvin you
change the temperature 10 Kelvin it
starts to - it's it feels a change of
temperature so all of a sudden the
magnetization jumps up and then it
starts to relax again after 800 minutes
you put it back at 12 Kelvin and what
happens is that it starts again and
and relaxes very slowly now here in the
in the top car what you have done what
they have done is you take off the
intermediate moment between 400 and 800
meters the one which was at 10 Kelvin
and you glue the two pieces and the two
pieces when they are glued they go
exactly on the relaxation that you would
have found if you had not changed the
temperature here so you have a system
which has extremely slow relaxation
memory of what it was doing and the new
dynamics that appears in the middle this
we have some idea of what way it is so
we have a there is a high D which is
related to the existence of many
metastable States with a hierarchical an
ultra matrix structure actually and
which can explain this kind of
experiment but that's not the end of my
talk it was just a slide to show you
that there are real experiments and
Spengler's
is also I want to tell you of one model
I will have just three or four slides on
this and this model of Inglis so that
you understand what is the model that
that people have been working on it's a
model with what we call 3-speed
interaction so you have again the easing
spins si which are binary variable plus
1 or minus 1 they interact with with
triplet interaction and the triplet can
be either we call it a placate
interaction so if J ijk is plus 1 it
favors the configuration where the spins
or per hour or one pointing up and two
down if j IJ K is minus one it favors
this these kind of configurations now
imagine that you take a system of spins
and and you generate randomly triplets
and you you create this energy function
and you look at the Boltzmann weight and
you drew a Monte Carlo simulation so you
try to generate equilibrium
configuration for this measure so this
for instance is the case who have a
simulation I show you you generally tend
to take a hundred thousand spins for try
and rest
in randomly chosen so you have a kind of
random hypergraph of interaction between
the spins
now you cool the system down you find
this this is the energy density and this
is this this is what you find when you
tend to the for Monte Carlo steps for
spin 10 to the 5 10 to the 6 10 to the 7
and you stop here and then you can show
that in this system if your your your
computer time it does not grow
exponentially with the size of the
system you will reach here inherently
limit in the kind of energy that you can
get at the zero temperature you should
get the ground state energy and the
ground state energy the true ground
state of the system is here so this is
exactly what is a glass face it has a
dynamical phase transition which is here
and basically it tells you that by doing
this this cooling you cannot go better
than this energy here and it has an
equilibrium phase transition which is
here which is called Hausman transition
so this is a theoretical construction
for the theory of glasses now all this
has created an enormous amount of work
as I told you tens of thousands of
papers just a few benchmark technically
there was a big boom in the in the field
at the end of the 70s with with the
introduction of the theory of replica
Theory in this system and replica
symmetry breaking in the eighties it was
understood that the system has many pure
states and Rama tricity
and then there was a development of what
is called the cavity method that is
something which is
which will have some influence or father
I will discuss it for the rest of the
talk
Phil Anderson again described in a
series of papers of offspring glasses he
described it as a cornucopia and
cornucopia because it has had influence
in in a very different in very different
fields as early as the early 80s there
was papers inspired by spring glass
ideas about matching traveling salesman
problem the neural network
satisfiability error correcting codes
and compressed sensing so why why is it
so well intrinsically spin glass theory
deals with the collective behavior so
that's the more is different and the
emergent properties of system made from
many different atoms okay that's the
field of statistical physics for
strongly disordered system so the atoms
can be very different things can be
magnetic moments in spin glasses
molecules in structural glasses
information bits neuron spikes that's
when you look at the information
processing in the brain logical
variables in constraint satisfaction
agents on a market etc so that's kind of
a global framework let's say for
analysis now this is interesting at the
same time it's very risky because when
you enter this kind of field there is
always this risk that you you have some
soft soft talked about extremely
Universal mechanism that everything is
the same in all these the various fields
and but that typically has absolutely no
impact on science now there is that's
the risk so we have to be conscious of
the risk now there is a remote goal and
the remote goal in my opinion is the
following we have in spin glass we have
the same kind of phases as we have in a
ferromagnet that is we have a kind of
collective phase which is extremely
robust but instead of having only two
states majority of spins pointing up or
majority of spins pointing down we have
many many states actually in some cases
an exponential number of states
and in and I think that the the remote
goal will be to try to understand how to
use these many states for having robust
computing and now apart from this from
remote goal there are some intermediate
steps and the intermediate steps are
it's it's like you know you want to
climb this mountain and the top of the
mountain is this remote goal and then on
the way towards the mountain you find
some some hints of interesting things
and and the intermediate steps are to
use ping glass concepts and methods to
provide a different viewpoint about
computation and to design new algorithms
and that's really I will focus today on
the intermediate steps because I don't
have much to say about the remote goal
but I will come back to the goal
later on so what are the concepts of you
I have already given you a few lists of
the concept phase phase transition
States glassy phase relaxation time and
the methods methods are basically mean
field approach replica method cavity
method today I will talk more about the
concepts and I will skip all that all
the techniques but the techniques are
crucial because if you do not have the
techniques you are not able to to apply
this concept so what I want to spend
some time on is to to show you that
really this notion of more is different
and this notion of the importance of
phase transition is actually very
important in several branch of computing
several branches of computing and I will
illustrate it with three examples error
correcting code satisfiability of
boolean formulas and compress sensing so
let me mention a few few things about
error correcting codes some very
standard and very well known results so
you want to send messages of length n
with binary alphabet
noisy Channel and messages you take them
from a codebook and the codebook has
size 2 to the L so you look at the I per
cube it has 2 to the N with the unit
hypercube in n dimension it has 2 to the
N points you select 2 to the L of them
you have the rate of the communication
which is a over N and then let me study
this in the thermodynamic limit some
dynamic limit is L and n goes to
infinity with fixed rate so look at you
read the Shannon for instance and and
you realize this the following result
actually by studying the simplest way is
to study an ensemble of codes so you
send you a random code and sample a
random code and somebody is very easy
you take this hypercube and you generate
the code words the code book just
randomly and you look at what is the
performance of this code and you find
the probability are ever of error passes
the noise level and the probability of
error sorry it should be ok this will be
0 and this would be 1 you have to flip
the
if okay probability of success this is a
priority of success probability of
success versus noise level it's
excessive in the large n limit in the
thermodynamic limit you have probability
of success which which has a phase
transition at a very well-defined
noise level and that's the Shannon
threshold okay it turns out that it is
the optimal thing that you can do now I
want to insist on two things the
thermodynamic limit this is a result in
thermodynamic limit and then it's a
property what is this property that you
are looking at it's a property of a
generic code drawn from an ensemble of
codes that's extremely typical of what
we do in statistical physics all the
time and in that sense I will be
completely my talk will be totally
orthogonal to the one of the of the
previous speaker that is I am NOT
looking at adversary situation I'm
looking at typical situation I am NOT
looking at the extremely rare
code the very bad code that you could
generate from a random code and sample
but I'm looking at the typical was now
this was one example of phase transition
now imagine that okay as we know random
code and sample does not allow you to
really
decode efficiently because it's
exponential time decoding so you start
to build or a structured code ensemble
like for instance low-density
parity-check code and you do you imagine
that you do you are able to do optimal
decoding with that again you have
you don't have time constraint for
decoding and then you find that if you
do that you have a phase transition
again at a different value of the other
noise paper and then you take always
your typical code and sample but now you
you introduce a practical algorithm one
that you are able to run in polynomial
time
for instance you look at message passing
decoding of the LDPC code and you find
that there is another threshold here now
you have this very so you have three
phase transitions in this in this
problem two of them are just purely
geometric phase transition there are
properties of the of the
of the hypercube basically the other one
this one is is a property of the
algorithm and it turns out that when you
look at the LDPC code this is due to a
glass transition a proliferation of
metastable States and so then as a
practitioner what you have to do is
basically to try to invent examples of
codes that that will be such that you
push this algorithmic threshold as close
as possible to the Tudor Shannon
threshold and as we know this this has
been done with quite some success
what is the geometrical picture for this
phase transition so this is my my view
of the of the unit hypercube in large I
mentioned you have a few code words I
have not described the others the other
points of the hypercube I put only the
code words this is the code word that
has been sent
imagine that I'm working for instance on
a binary symmetric channel which flips
some some bits randomly so then I start
from this from this point from this
codeword I receive this one because of
the noise of the channel and then if I
know the properties of the channel
basically I know how many bids have been
flipped because I know the noise level
and I just need to find a codeword on
this sphere which is a sphere given by
the level of noise and now there may
happen several things it may happen that
there is a single codeword and at the
favorable situation it may happen that
there are many code words on the sphere
and then you are unable to retrieve and
it may happen something intermediate in
which you have a single code word but
you have also a lot of metastable States
exactly these metastable States that I
was mentioning in the Indus pingas
programs and that is exactly what
happens if you look back at the phase
you have this first region on the Left
where the algorithm is successful it
means that basically on the sphere you
have a single code well that is that is
present you have this intermediate phase
in which in principle on the sphere
there is a single code world but because
of the proliferation of metastable
States the message passing decoding does
not converge and that is the existence
of the glass phase that pulls the
algorithm itself and then of course if
you go in this other region you have
many code words on the sphere and you
are not able to retrieve at all so this
is an example of the importance of phase
transition in this field you have a
fundamental threshold which is due to a
phase transition in one ensemble and
then you look at a practical example you
have the fundamental transition for this
ensemble and then you have the
transition the phase transition for the
algorithm itself now my second example
is satisfiability of boolean formulas so
imagine that you so you look at at
random k satisfiability you take n
binary variable true or false 0 1 and
then you put M constraints which are
closes and closes involve K variables
here it's with 3 variable x1 or not x2
or x3 and now I look at this problem in
the again I have a like a thermodynamic
limit so you see I have introduced an
ensample I generate the clauses randomly
I have a thermodynamic limit and an M
goes to infinity with fixed ratio M over
N number of clauses per variable and my
question is what is the generic property
of the instance dependent measure which
is the uniform measure overall the
satisfiable assignment if there is no
satisfiable assignment I could introduce
as a physicist I will introduce a
temperature and it would mean that I
introduce an energy which is a number of
a relative clause and the Boltzmann
weight related with related to this
energy so when you look at the
thermodynamic limit of this problem
initially the initial simulations in
particular by Bath Selma and Kirkpatrick
and so on and this has been refined a
lot have observed that as function of
the size of the problem the probability
that the formula is satisfiable function
of alpha the number of clauses per
variable displays the following behavior
this is what you observe numerically
with n equal 50 the green is with n
equal 100 and and the and the red is
with n equal 200 okay and so this
becomes sharper and sharper actually the
threshold conjecture says states that
there should be the probably should go
to 1 in the large n limit below some
threshold alpha C and should go to 0
above alpha C it still
conjecture that is a very nice result by
Fred good that shows that it goes to a
step function but the fact that the step
that the location of the step function
converges in vulajin limit has not been
proven that I know so far so it is
because of that it is still a conjecture
but okay it is a conjecture but it is a
phase transition now you think that has
really created quite a lot of interest
on this problem is the fact that the
phase transition which is here is also
associated with with the kind of
complexity window that is if you look at
the log of the number of at the log of
the computer time that you need in order
to do these experiments this for n equal
50 100 200 you see that its growth the
computer time goes exponentially and
actually the most difficult instances
are the one which are in the window
close to the phase transition itself so
the phase transition is really where you
generate the hard instances of random
satisfiability so this again is a
problem that it in some sense it looks
like like this problem of interacting
spin glasses that I was describing at
the beginning that is it has it has
these binary variables that interact
here by triplet and and
the question is whether it's possible to
satisfy all the constraints by looking
at this problem from using the
techniques of statistical physics or
disordered system when comes up with
with couple of results which are also
conjectures the first conjecture is a
location of the of the transition point
and the location a transition point it
should be alpha C equal four point two
six six seven and I could generate a
list if the solution of a complicated
into our equation that one can write but
the thing which is more spectacular is
the fact that right below the transition
point this is again the number of
constraints per variable right below
this to this critical point we have an
intermediate phase so there is a
geometry that two geometric transition
this is the sat unsub transition it
separates the region the number of
constraints above the threshold the
system is unset below it itself but when
it is sat there are two phases and here
the idea is the following you have
imagine that you color in green the
states the points of the of the
hypercube again which are satisfiable
configuration and you will have when the
density of constraint is small it turns
out that the solutions are all grouped
in one big cluster so they are connected
one to the other you can go from a
solution to the other one by flipping a
variable at a time and so you can you
you have this big connected cluster and
then at some critical value again
another critical threshold what happens
is that this big connected cluster of
solution splits into very far away a
large number of clusters of solution
these are the green clusters and and the
green clusters of solution inside each
cluster of solution you can you can go
from a solution to the other one but if
you want to move from this cluster to
the other one you need a collective move
of a fraction of a finite fraction of
the n variables so this is extremely
this is a very complicated phase that
this is what I call from easy sad phase
and the heart sad face now I want to
show you exactly how it goes so at in
terms of the energy the number of
violated Clause basically in this phase
where you have one Big C connected C of
solutions and you might have some
metastable states that you don't care so
much about and then here you have this
intermediate phase in which you have the
clusters of solution and the thing which
is very important is that going from
here to there you need really to flip a
finite fraction of the value and then
you have a TV unsatisfied so this is
these are the results that can be
obtained by looking at this problem from
the point of view of using the tools
from statistical physics you can also
compute these these thresholds all these
have the stages of conjectures in the
sense that even the existence of the
phase transition itself is still a
conjecture but they are supported by
several by several argument first of all
when you realize that there is
intermediate phase this intermediate
phase I should I should insist sorry on
one point that the in this intermediate
phase you have an exponentially large
number of clusters of solution and
inside each cluster it also has an
exponentially large number of solution
so this is exactly what I was mentioning
before about this remote goal we have a
system which has exponentially large
states and each state is very robust
because each state is the collection
it's in itself of an exponentially large
number of solutions so when you realize
that
it allows to design a new algorithm
which is really based on the idea of the
existence of this class trois and this
this algorithm which is called survey
propagation it was a kind of I mean our
intention originally was not to build an
algorithm because I am I am a furious in
statistical physics so my intention was
to understand the phase diagram and the
phase transition but then we realized
that there is this intermediate phase
and that this intermediate phase having
this exponentially large number of
clusters of solution one has to modify
in this intermediate phase the standard
belief propagation algorithm has to be
turned into something which is called
survey propagation and in practice of a
propagation turns out to be an extremely
powerful algorithm for this for this
problem in the heart sad face and I
should also mention that there is a
rigorous proof of the existence of
clusters and the fact that they are well
separated at least when K is larger than
seven is based on the existence of the
under study of what we call X
satisfiable formula formula is X
satisfiable when it is satisfied by two
assignments at distance X N and then you
look at standard upper and lower bounds
using first and second moment method
about the existence of X that is viable
formulas and you find that above the top
line there are no you are sure that
there are no solution the formula is not
X satisfiable X is in the abscissa below
the bottom line you are sure that it is
X satisfiable and so you find that there
is this window in which that's in some
region you are sure there are some
clusters so X small you can have two
points which are nearby and which
satisfied the solution which are two
solutions in the intermediate X region
it's not possible to have two solutions
and in the large exposure region it's
possible again so we
proof of the existence of the trust so
this was my second example and I want to
turn into a third example and on the
importance of a phase transition and
it's some recent work that we have been
doing with some colleagues and
uncompress sensing every child knows
literally that that you can compress the
pictures you can compress the music and
so on and and basically if you take one
image and you take 65,000 wavelet
coefficients keep only the 25,000
largest ones you get the image pretty
much correct let's say all interesting
signals are sparse so this has been used
a lot for compression now the more
recent trend is to try to use it at the
level of data acquisition and this is
something that has has a lot of possible
applications in particular in magnetic
resonance imaging tomography electron
microscopy astronomy etc and also in
some more advanced setting which are
nonlinear measurement like group testing
and the in fear of regulatory
interactions among many genes using gene
expression data which you can do only
limited experimental conditions I will
just tell you a few things about the
simplest one the simplest setting father
for this compressed sensing problem
which is one of linear transforms so you
have a signal it is an N component
signal let's say with real component you
do some measurements on this signal
these measurements are linear
measurements and so each measurement you
do M measurement so y1 is a certain
linear combination of the signal y2 also
and so on
so this the set of measurements is
summarizing a measurement matrix which
is M times n mate
now you do a number of measurements M
which is more than a number of component
n and your problem is to reconstruct the
signal from the measurement so in
principle you are missing data the thing
that is very important is that you
assume that the signal is passed so you
are going to correct basis we are the
signal is passed so it means that you
want to exploit the fact that you know
that the signal has only are nonzero
components is this possible well you
will soon realize that if you generate
for instance F randomly where I will
discuss mostly the case in which the
elements of F I have an ensemble in
which the elements of F are independent
Gaussian random numbers if you generate
F randomly you look at this problem and
you see that it's possible to do that by
enumeration that is basically you'd
guess what are the nonzero element of s
and then you see that you have more
equations than unknowns and so if your
guess was correct you will have a
consistent set of equation if your guess
was incorrect you will have a new
consistent set of equation so you look
at all the gases there are n choose R of
them and then you you can do it of
course that's not a practical algorithm
it's exponential in the in the large n
limit so
I will be interested in in looking at an
ensemble with Gaussian f and in the
thermodynamic limit n MN are going to
infinity with a fixed density of the
signal the number of nonzero component
per variable and the fixed fraction of
measurement with respect to the number
of unknowns so this is possible by
numeration but it but not practical
because the XL garita mix is exponential
it's possible and it has been studied a
lot and that's where most of the work of
nearly nearly all the work on compressed
sensing deals with l1 relaxation of the
problem in the l1 relaxation of the
problem basically what you want to do is
to minimize the l1 norm of s on the
subspace y equal F s you look at this
subspace minimize well one norm
minimizing the l1 norms tends to bring
some elements to zero and then you look
at the result of this l1 norm so this
has given the following result a phase
diagram again the phase diagram is
written here here in terms of Rho is the
density of the signal the fraction of
nonzero component alpha is the number of
measurement per variable so if alpha is
larger than one you know how to solve
the problem because you have more
equation than unknown so that's easy and
the whole problem is to get to alpha
less than 1 what I told you is that
basically what you need is to be above
this diagonal about this diagonal it's
possible to do it by enumeration with an
exponentially slow algorithm below the
diagonal it's impossible you don't have
enough data now the thing that
face the study of this phase diagram by
Tanner and then there were other works
later by Mishima and so on the the phase
diagram shows a phase transition for the
l1 reconstruction and this is the line
that is that is written here this phase
transition separates region where you
have alpha larger than a certain
critical threshold so you have enough
information to reconstruct from a region
which is a blue region in which the l1
reconstruction is wrong it is it is
wrong because by doing this l1
relaxation you have changed the problem
you're under trying the the real problem
should be to minimize the he'll 0 norm
to find the to find a value of s which
which minimize the number of nonzero
component and so in some sense so this
is a measure of the success of Al once
it goes from the original method that
was alpha equal 1 and it feels or this
green region where the l1 relaxation is
okay now what we what we what we try to
do is to try to get into this forbidden
region let's say and so to go beyond the
l1 relaxation using the probabilistic
approach so we have a cell signal and
somewhere in which the the signal is
equal to 0 is probability 1 minus for
not and for is probability R or not is
roll from a distribution find out of s
which can be any distribution you like
and basically we study now the
reconstruction measure and this
reconstruction measure it's a measure
which is inside the subspace y equal FX
it's a measure on X it's it has to be
compatible with the measurement and what
we use is a Gauss bernoulli prior on X
with a certain density Rho and then
there is a theorem which says that if
alpha is less than Rho know that if you
are above the diagonal in the in the
phase diagram the most probable x is the
original signal test so if you are able
to sample correctly from this measure
then you get to the result so this is a
non-trivial
because it's intuitive in the case where
I rode Rho is equal to Rho not but it's
true actually even if it is not the case
so it tells you one thing it tells you
that for iid signals bias reconstruction
is in principle optimal even if the
prior is not the correct one now in
order to reconstruct from this measure
we have used this belief propagation
procedure and it has some very nice
aspect it is fast introduced to noise
and it's generalizable to nonlinear
measurement and they have no time to
describe exactly how it goes but let me
show the results this is again my phase
diagram now this is the phase diagram
with the reconstruction threshold and
the final phase transition for the l1
relaxation of the problem and now I look
at the case in which the non zero
component of the of the signal are
Gaussian and I am using a Gaussian prior
when the reconstruction so you have a
good idea of the distribution of the
nonzero component of the signal and then
what we see is that there is also a
phase transition for this probabilistic
reconstruction using belief propagation
and this reconstruction it has the phase
tradition which is here so you see that
I have gained with respect to l1 I have
really been now I am able to solve in
this region which was previously it was
forbidden and now it's possible now if I
am using still a Gaussian prior for my
for my for the this
sorry here I use my signal the nonzero
component of the signal are generated
from binary component binary
distribution plus 1 or minus 1 but I
assume that I don't know that and so I
am using myself in the reconstruction I
do as if as
it was a Gaussian distribution so I have
a very bad prior with my very bad prior
again in some region I can go beyond l1
but basically the game is is not is not
very he is very bad
now what is the reason for this phase
transition I told you that in principle
the Provost ik reconstruction is optimal
if I am able to sample from this measure
and the reason is that yes the measure
is the correct one but again the beauty
propagation algorithm is fooled by a
glass face and here is an example of
that I look at row equal point four I
look at the mean square error as
function of the number of iterations the
lines are computed analytically from the
cavity method and the points are the
results of experiment if I start from
alpha equal point 62 that's way above
the transition in media very soon after
a few tens of iteration I go to zero
error alpha equal point sixty I have an
intermediate time but then I go to zero
error so I am still above the transition
here and then alpha less than point five
fifty-eight I go to an infinite plateau
this the relaxation time of the system
is infinite so the system is extremely
slow so it's extremely sluggish and
there is no way to avoid this very onset
of a glass fence the idea is the
following
you have in this measure in this measure
that I am looking at there is a special
point and the special point is is this
original signal from which the measure
was generated it's like a crystalline
state and you want to reach this
crystalline state it was exactly like
the cold world that I had in in in our
error correcting code it's a very
special point that I want to find but
then there is a multiplicity of
metastable States that fools the system
but that's from the point of view of the
physicist that's exactly the situation
that you have if you have a system which
has a crystalline state but you are not
able to find the crystal that happens
very frequently
actually a lot of systems if you if you
cool them fast for instance they don't
crystallize they go to a glass state and
once they are in this glass state it
goes there for ages you have these
glasses for the cathedrals you have been
here for centuries and they will not
they will not move and they will not
crystallize and you know from the
mathematics that the stable state of the
system is the crystal but it's no there
is no point in waiting so how do you so
how do you do in such a in such a
problem well actually there is a way to
get if you are able to design your
measurement matrix and I will assume
that I'm allowed to do that here then
there is a way to get around the glass
trap and it is exactly the way how do
you nucleate a crystal to build a
crystal if you want to make a good
crystal avoiding this glass what you do
it's not waiting it's not by waiting
longer and longer and having a bigger
computer computer time does not help but
you do is just you have to nucleate the
crystalline state and then let it grow a
crystal grows okay and so in order to do
that what you do is that you have this
so this is just an illustration that I
got from from YouTube actually about how
a crystal grows so this is this is snow
so it's outside the supercooled water so
it's water but it is below zero degree
and then at some point at some point the
experimentalist drops some piece of ice
at the at the top of the thing and then
you see that the ice the the
water crystallizes the crystal is
growing very rapidly actually because of
problem of specific heat and so and it
does not fully crystallize I still a
mixture of water because you need to
have transfer of heat it's a complicated
problem in itself but that is you have
this idea that the crystallization when
you have put a certain seed of a crystal
then it can grow very fast and that's
exactly what what what you can do in
this measurement matrix and I what who
will do is construct a measurement
matrix which our initial measurement
matrix was what we call mean field in
physics that is it it meant that in each
measurement you had a linear combination
of all the variables now what I will do
is the following
I attach system of the variables as a
second subsystem third subsystem etc
inside each subsystem I will I will have
a mean field construction of the
measurement matrix and then I add a one
dimensional structure and then in the
first subsystem I will put a lot of
measurement I have a large value of the
number actually I put alpha equal one I
put enough measurement as many
measurements as unknown in the first
system and then in the other ones I can
have low values of the measurement and
the idea is that if things go well
I will first decode the first subsystem
grow my crystal and then the crystal
will will propagate and that's exactly
what will happen here is the variance of
the matrix so all my elements of the
random matrix of measurements are
Gaussian random variables and this is
the value of the variance so you see on
the block which are on the diagonal I
have variance which is equal to 1 J 1
below diagonal Dre 2 above diagonal and
the first block is larger for block is
larger because I have to put many
measurement on the first group of
variables so that when I decode these
variables they will propagate the
information in a one dimensional way and
that's exactly what what happens in
practice and that's what we call CDD
belief propagation and when we do that
we find that we can we can decode
experimental numerical result we can
decode pretty well going very close to
the diagonal also in the case in which
the prior that we use is not the correct
one so it means that there is a way at
least if you have enough power to design
your measurement there is a way to
really get around this glass trap and
actually I should mention that this is
also something that has been used in in
error correcting codes for the exactly
the same reason but it's the same
problem that you have that you have a
glass phase that you have to to get
around except that people who were doing
that in error correcting codes they did
not use this reasoning in terms of
crystals and glass and so on that the
result is the same so this is a case in
which so that the phase diagram
analytically we can show that in the
large and in the thermodynamic limit we
can decode down to the diagonal so we
can solve the problem of Fuli that was
for iid signals actually it also works
in the case where the signals are not
iid this is a phantom and when you do a
first step of how transforming off and
your phantom you have a lot of zero
element so it has a density point 15
that's the l1 decoding on the first row
and you see that l1 stops to be correct
around point between 0.5 and point four
that the standard BP decoding without
seeding and it stops it stops to be
correct at point three and that the
seeded VP and the CD BP goes all the way
it gives you back the phantom correctly
all the way to the to the density that's
so it shows that this algorithm that has
been invented and designed for iid
signal here the signal is not at all a
ID it's what it is it's a hard transform
of this of this phantom
so just one yes so I have just one word
about methods I have said that they have
no time to discuss methods here I wanted
to show you the importance of phase
transition
I should insist on the fact that all
these method that we use mean field
approach replica cavity cavity is
strongly related to the to the to the
belief propagation approach basically
the full control on this method is in
some specific situations not in not in
all cases but you have locally tree-like
interaction or long-range interaction in
which really the mean field can be can
be good order in in full generality let
me sorry just
yes I just wanted in the last two
minutes go back to to the to this idea
of the future of computing in some sense
what I see in all this approach are kind
of building blocks of something that
could be useful for the future of
computing and again I want to insist on
this possibility that is illustrated
here on KSAT but that we have seen we
have witnessed it in other systems as
well which is the existence of this
intermediate class phase it's an
intermediate class phase which has a
very very clear meaning again I remind
you you have vertices of the hypercube
some of them satisfy the boolean formula
that you had and others not I color in
in green the one that had sat satisfied
and I find that in some intermediate
window between four point between four
and four point three basically you have
an intermediate phase in which the set
of solutions cluster and the clusters
they are exponentially many clusters
they are very well separated one from it
other it's inside each cluster there is
an exponential number of solutions this
is something which I find extremely a
priori something very useful it's like
having a magnet
you know it's but instead of having my
magnet which points at one down it can
point in exponentially many different
directions but it has the same
robustness it means that if I if I just
change you know I put a little bit of
disorder and so and I will have the same
the same the same robustness and so that
is something that should be Posse it
should be possible to use it
it's an extremely robust structure it's
found in many system now the questions
for the for the future is how to control
how to design how to address these
States can you use them
we have already a few hints that maybe
something is possible in particular when
we want to solve the problem of KSAT in
this intermediate phase if you if we use
message passing and reinforcement we
have a way to locate some of these of
these clusters of solution without any a
priori knowledge so it seems that there
is a way to address them but we have
still not found a way to use it for for
computing so this was tapper of last
comments the states they exist only in
large size systems so it's really a
property of large-scale computing so
it's not something that is universal and
so on it's not building a small device
it's really for large size problem all
this is based on the analogies of
examples of problems and typical
behavior of an ensemble of problem and
there I want to quote some some
discussion that I had with with some
colleagues computer scientists around
the dinner of two years ago and they had
learned about what we do in physics and
they told me well but you in in physics
you always think that nature is
benevolent there is no you know there is
no adversary in your in your field and
actually that's probably true that is
again all the properties everything that
I tell you is the typical property is
the property of a typical sample when I
tell you a spin glasses is like this I
like that I have in mind the following I
put impurities of manganese in copper
and then I say there will be a spring
glass transition at 12 Kelvin okay
but now it might happen that from my
case it might happen that this impurity
of manganese they all are at such
distance one from each other that
actually my system is not as fingers
it's a ferromagnet and then the
transition is not at 12 Kelvin but it
will be at hundreds of Kelvin it's
completely different except that this is
exponentially rare because it's
something that should have been designed
if you do it
you never find it so for me nature is
benevolent in the sense that yes things
that happen exponentially rarely like I
don't know having no error in this no
molecule of error in the in this but
here I don't care about it it never
happens of course if I have an hour an
anniversary that is able to pump the air
just in front of my mouth it could be
risky but I'm not trained in thinking in
this that's why nature is benevolent I
have not talked about techniques but
techniques are very interesting in
themselves and again I mean see the
techniques are crucial because none of
these bricks that I'm trying to show
could have been developed without
without the techniques and replica
cavity are really extremely useful tools
they translate from the point of view of
algorithm into message passing
strategies message passing in is in
itself is is again an interesting brick
because I think that it is intrinsically
very robust you know if I look at survey
propagation algorithm for case hab I
have my message is that I change a to
and in the end I find this satisfiable
assignment where in the region we are no
other algorithm is able to do it I can I
can put noise on these messages it does
not okay I will get only a little less
performance but still it will converge
to the same thing so it's it's something
it's a it's a robust type of computation
and also I have in mind the following
thing that this message passing approach
it's also related to
exchange of information when you when
you have spikes spike propagating along
a neuron liberating neurotransmitters
going to another spike that's the kind
of message transmission and so knowing
that you are able to do extremely
difficult computation or obviously using
this kind of paradigm I find that it is
a some opening for for the future of
computing I hope I have convinced you
that that more is actually different
also in computing and here are a few
couple of references and I should now
let some of my collaborators on these
topics and in particular special thanks
to Joe Joe Parisi with whom we developed
the cavity method I gathered the kina
with whom we did the K satisfiability
and cyclins the bhava with whom we did
the recent work on compressed sensing
thank you very much
resize if you look at approximability
you visit the same base transition so if
you look at the optimal number of
clauses they can satisfies and divided
by the number of clauses that you did
that like belief propagation client you
get a phase transition or is it
I think if I convert it into physics
language it would mean about what is the
energy of the what I call ground state
energy what is the smallest number of
violated Clause and so here no you will
have something which is continuous from
this point of view I mean the phase
transition exists only if you ask the
question is there zero is there a
solution with zero energy with zero
violated flows or not if you are in the
in the unset region and you ask what is
the energy this one has no has no
transition but but from the point of
view but there is still a clustered
phase from this point of view that is in
the region which is unset you still have
some region of parameters in which the
the thing which are not solutions but
the configurations which satisfy the
largest number of clauses group into
distinct clusters which are far away
from each other they are not at zero
energy they are at some finite energy
but they still have this crest
clustering property and this impact on
the dynamics of algorithm when you want
to find them
we know where this curve looked like I
we have not I mean the problem with that
is that you don't have a signature that
is I can give you some prediction but I
cannot prove that my prediction is
correct I mean when I say I have a
prediction that in this region below
four point two six something it is sad
and then I I prove it and I exhibit the
fact but if I tell you I think that in
this that for this value of alpha 4
Alpha equal four point four the smallest
number of violated Clause is equal to
0.3 percent or I don't know I invent a
number I can I can have a prediction
like that but it's a conjecture that I
have no way of proving to you proving I
mean documenting
because
symmetric interactions is there any
loosen madness will get
yes I think that yes there is quite some
actually there are some recent moves
which I find very interesting which is
going to okay when you want to exactly
what you what you say when you want to
go to to neural networks I think that
that you have is more dynamical process
rather than an equilibrium measure
that's the thing which is more natural
and it turns out that there is a some
some work in the last two or three years
which starts to to study the problem of
spatial temporal spin class in some
sense in which the the basic object is
not the value of a spin or where you
have a neuron or a spike but it's it's
time trajectory so it's a more
complicated object but then you can
start to develop the same kind of ideas
but working with time trajectories of
the system it has been studied actually
in two contexts one is the study of
dynamical system with a remote goal of
trying to to develop a better theory of
neural network from this point of view
the other one is is for quantum spin
glasses because if you look at the
quantum spin glass you have exactly this
you can use fineman's representation and
it develops into a time trajectory of a
spin and it's exactly the same thing so
in recent years there have been a few
papers dealing with
belief propagation and so and for
space-time trajectories of the of the
spirit and I think this is something
very interesting of course
it's it's much more the complete there
is an intrinsic complexity by the fact
that you are the intrinsic variable is
much more compact then it will depend
very much I think the possibility of
success in this approach will depend
very much on is it possible to have a
short description of the trajectory in
time of the neuron that is if it is an
extremely complex trajectory occur you
cannot parameterize it on a small
relating the small number of parameters
then it will be very hard to progress
it probably has its own yes the question
is whether survey propagation algorithm
is able to solve the random
satisfiability problem up to the
threshold to the Saturn's a threshold
and the answer is I don't exactly know I
don't have a but but numerically it
seems that it stops before slightly
before and it's okay it's it's
complicated it's difficult to know
exactly why actually the situation is
yes Jason is complicated it's not the
same I should also mention that it's not
the same for 3sat and for for or larger
equal to for sat large or equal to four
there is another transition that is well
known which is where you can show that
survey propagation does not go beyond
that second transition 3sat it might be
possible numerically you got very close
I mean I I have it working at 4.2
certainly and the threshold analytical
threshold is four point two six seven
and then you start to enter into
problems of finite size effect because
you see all these works actually these
are interesting the algorithm because
the algorithm which worked better
the larger the problem and when we first
put survey propagation on the web people
that downloaded it and was using it for
systems of size 5,000 and then sometimes
it works on Titan and say oh don't use
it for fighters and put 50,000 to
500,000 it will work much better because
the system itself is the having the
ideas behind that our idea phase
transition and you need to have more